guys we are gonna do one more call
tonight and we're gonna finish out the
show I can only
talk for so long this has made me really
appreciate live shows because I'm like I
gotta think of a lot more things to say
when it's just me
like oh my God like in the live shows I
can be quiet for a little bit
um all right blessing you ready to
accept the final caller
all right let's give them I'm gonna give
them a second I'm gonna go three two one
open the call line and then
oh someone said Aaron Cleary is making
woman his woman pay his rent that's why
he can say it's not cohabitation oh
that's interesting
tell me when you accept it
yeah you hi this is Pearl you're live on
the air
hi Pearl how are you
doing great
so the question is what is the solution
to Modern dating going forward for men
and for women
I think it's a a pretty tough thing to
solve
um without major like societal changes
so I just got back into the dating
Market
um I lost a bunch of weight during covid
so I'm a lot healthier now
and I I found a woman that
um I liked a lot and she likes me
I had to kind of adjust my dating
strategy to to make this all viable I
chose
um
basically to get a vasectomy before I
started dating again
so I thought it was too risky to try to
navigate the waters and risk being
I don't know baby trapped by someone so
I decided to go that route I'm uh like
40 years old right now and although even
like guys don't have uh like a timeline
per se I don't really want a kid past
45. so I just took the
what I thought was the best essential
but what I can make the the best out of
the rest of my life and aim to have a
partner that wants to be with me
and I found like a lot of women in their
say later 30s they wanted to have a kid
more than they want to have a partner
so that was a big risk to me so then
like something that then back to the
marriage thing how do we solve it I
think from the legal standpoint you need
to
um first of all have some sort of
consequence for getting divorced there
needs to be
the same let's say that brought in
um the legal challenges that needs to be
you know in terms of Family Court treat
men as having 50 50 custody as a default
and you would have to prove why that
should not be the case men should not be
giving up additional resources to try to
get back to 50 50. in terms of child
custody
um so a number of
changes that way the way that marriage
is currently written it still has
Traditional Values in mind and it hasn't
really kept up with the rest of society
um in terms of what can we do to women
to make what can they do differently and
I kind of feel like oh sorry no um yeah
sorry keep going going keep going it's
not it's not what sorry sorry it's not
what can women do differently it's like
what should women do now so do women
require marriage before they have
children do they still should they still
require marriage
um how long should they wait if so how
long should they wait to get married
like what what is a woman's blueprint
going forward
I think
um you need to spend something on the
order of probably like a year together
be in a committed relationship I mean
that's what marriage meant before
anyways being committed to each other so
um um as long as someone's committed you
don't necessarily need the contract to
prove that the case
um
like I think if the guy is willing to
show the woman to his family and vice
versa that's
obviously like a a pretty good sign like
you have to kind of build upon that
and uh share some of your life together
before you should start creating kids
together
um I'm curious do you have children
no I don't okay and so would you by
getting the vasectomy are you would you
if you found the right girl would you
reverse it or no
because you said you're 40. I found
someone that doesn't want kids oh okay
yeah like that was my goal in the end I
mean I was never
super gung-ho about
um having kids right now anyways
and like I said I was overweight from
from both 30 until just like a couple
years ago so I never even bothered
dating for about 10 years I just got
back into the market
um within the past couple years or so
okay so I think I think there needs to
be like um I think educating uh the
younger generation to show what are
these various options that you have if
you wanna if you want to focus on hard
career and you want to be
um like a boss babe so go ahead go ahead
and do that but then understand the
consequences of what that means
and understand that
like uh women are going to be on a
timeline I think you need to reinforce
women being more effeminine and men
being more masculine and uh cater meant
to be in those like leadership roles I
think that would help out men be
stronger as well and then become more
desirable to women
so like a lot of those things take time
to
to change and I don't think it's
changing overnight some of the legal
um things I talked about could I could
change people with the right political
party in power let's say but
even that would take years to implement
and I just like Community personally
because I'm already 40. I didn't see
that changing in a timely enough fashion
to uh to try to like form the rest of my
life on
no and it's interesting I never even
thought of a vasectomy as an option for
men but
I just didn't want to get baby trapped
by someone yeah and valid fear there's a
couple of situations where because I was
dating a lot um the end of last year and
I'm in a committed relationship there's
a couple of times that gave me a few
scares and I'm glad I had that surgery
he's like I'm not playing it's not ideal
like I'm not I'm not playing with you
it's not it's not a good it's not a good
end game plan because yeah I know that
if every guy did what I did
um then there's no new kids there's no
new generation right yeah
okay well um this that was interesting
so thank you for calling in
um I never even thought of the second
thanks for having me yeah I think thank
you
okay that's that's our last caller for
the night so
guys we had some interesting ideas I
liked the renewal the marriage license
renewal that's an interesting solution
um
I like the idea of like the new
generation focusing on them they wait
but I don't think that's probable
likely especially I see what's going on
in high school these days they're wild
oh my God
um a vasectomy that's interesting
do we have any other interesting ones
my laptop died otherwise I'd read for my
notes
um I it seems like moving forward a lot
of it seems like the new Norm may not
even be marriage it may just be
long-term relationships
actually that could be that could be a
whole stream should women require
marriage before they carry
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible